he's the author of this book lawless
world and welcome and thanks for joining
us
terrific to be with you we are going to
talk about I guess the British support
for the Iraq war and to start I like to
refer to a column that appeared in The
Guardian this morning the British
newspaper this is by Timothy Garton ash
and this is what he writes he says how
will history that old ventriloquist
dummy judge Blair's legacy and foreign
policy when he goes will he and his
government's have left Britain with a
better name in the world my preliminary
judgment is that he deserves to have and
he should have but I'm not sure that he
will have and this is for one reason
only Iraq how would you respond to that
I think it's pretty clear that one of
the big legacies for the Blair
government and he's been in power for
approaching ten years is going to be the
war in Iraq and at the heart of that
issue is not how the walk was prosecuted
the consequences but actually the
question that every Brit is asking why
did Tony Blair support george w bush
it's a question that I get asked
wherever I speak all over the world it's
a complex question I'm still not sure
what the answer is what answer do you
give well I think it's a complex issue
that essentially turns on the view of a
British prime minister who believed the
Britain's place at the end of the day
for right or for wrong was beside the
United States I happen to think it was
wrong and I think it was wrong as I
described in the book because the war
was unlawful and that's essentially what
the thrust of the book is about but I
think Tony Blair to give him credit
tried very very hard to persuade George
Bush to go for a second UN resolution a
resolution which would explicitly
authorize the use of force and the
material that has come out this week in
the New York Times indicates in fact
that as early as January 2003 a couple
of months before the war the deal was a
done deal it didn't matter what happened
in the Security Council there was going
to be a war in Iraq and I think that's
going to haunt certainly Prime Minister
Tony Blair over the long term and I
suspect also George W Bush that memo was
talked about a new book could you give
us a synopsis of what that memo
contained yeah the the memo relates to a
meeting that was held here in DC on the
31st of January 2003 it's been described
in Bob woods ins book as the famous
second resolution meeting
and it was the moment at which the Prime
Minister and the president discussed
where do we go next is there to be a
second resolution or not the memo is
important for two reasons first it
confirms the decision had already been
taken by the end of January
unambiguously the president tells the
Prime Minister irrespective of the
second resolution we are going to war in
Iraq but secondly and I think even more
significantly it confirms that neither
the president nor the Prime Minister had
any real evidence of weapons of mass
destruction they had I think a belief
the weapons of mass destruction were
present in Iraq but no evidence
whatsoever and that's why for example
President Bush suggests to Tony Blair we
may take US spy planes paint them in UN
colors send them up and when he shoes of
them will have a pretext for going to
war you don't need to do that if you've
got evidence of weapons of mass
destruction when did this meeting take
place in perspective to the presentation
that Colin Powell gave at the UN good
question it took place five days before
: Powell's meeting Colin Powell went to
the Security Council on the 5th of
February so one would have expected at a
meeting on the 31st of January just
before that meeting for the president of
the prime minister to know that what
Colin Powell had was The Smoking Gun was
the evidence that will persuade at the
rest of the world and I read the event
of that time as an indication that in
fact they knew that Colin Powell's
presentation would not succeed in
persuading the rest of the world as in
fact it did not mm remember how does
that differ from the Downing Street memo
the Downing Street memo concerns an
internal UK sub cabinet meeting in July
2002 it was in fact the original edition
of my book that brought that out in some
reform also that concerns a discussion
between British Cabinet ministers
government ministers on what would
happen in the coming months in relation
to Iraq and it's been significant
because it's clear in the Downing Street
memo of July 2002 that they were
proceeding on the basis that the British
prime minister had already committed
himself to support President Bush and so
it's all rather consistent in hanging
together
in painting I think a picture which
suggests my view is the decision in
principle was taken
in March April 2002 and thereafter it
was a question of finding a
justification a pretext for making it
happen
the justification was weapons of mass
destruction and of course as we know
there were not our guest is with us
until 8:30 you can call him and ask him
questions at 202 seven thirty seven zero
zero zero two four Democrats 202 seven
thirty seven zero zero zero one for
Republicans and two oh two six two eight
zero two zero five for independence
Prime Minister Blair has been making a
series of foreign policy speeches what
do you gather as a the intent for these
speeches
one in London one in Australia and want
to be made here in the United States
foreign policy is an issue that he came
to government very strongly committed to
he made a series of important speeches
one that he made in Chicago in 1999 I
thought was hugely important and one
that I was very supportive of and lest
it be said that I'm you know someone who
comes out and opposes Tony Blair at all
steps I supported him on all of his
other Wars I thought the war in
Afghanistan was was right and was lawful
I thought the war in Kosovo in 1999 also
was justifiable and Iraq is
distinguishable but what characterizes
Tony Blair is a concern about Britain's
place in the world and Britain's ability
to have both the close relationship with
the United States and with the European
community and it's been a difficult
balance to follow on top of that you've
also got Britain's historical
relationship with its former colonies
now arranged in the Commonwealth so
Britain stands at this curious place of
having a degree of influence sometimes
described as punching above its weight
and I think Tony Blair was acutely aware
of that and I think right up until Iraq
had taken essentially the right approach
in promoting Britain's interests in the
world and I think it's very regrettable
and tragic in his case that Iraq will be
the legacy rather than the other things
that have that have gone rather better
how does his own party look at him in
light of Iraq well you've probably heard
that there's considerable disquiet now
there was recently a general election in
Britain a year ago and he won that just
his share of the poll went down very
dramatically and they squeaked in
they've got a reasonable majority but
it's much tougher and the big question
now is when will he leave famously the
Prime Minister said a year ago or so ago
that he
not be standing for a fourth term he's
recently said it may have been a mistake
to have made that concession but the
question now is not who will succeed
because it's likely to be Gordon Brown
who I think is well known here in the US
but when will it happen and there's a
big debate as to whether within the
labor parties in Blair's interests to
stay longer or to go sooner to allow
Brown time to get over from Iraq Brown
is going to have to distance himself
from Iraq and from a range of other
issues I think if he's to restore
credibility for the Labour Party in
British government politics so it's an
interesting time in Britain is the
distance a disagreement with Prime
Minister Blair on why why they went to
Iraq Gordon Brown has had been totally
silent about the war in Iraq had really
never spoken about it and in the
election in May 2005 there was a
decisive a single decisive moment in the
middle of the election campaign the
Attorney General's legal advice the
British Attorney General's legal advice
on the war in Iraq was leaked and it
showed that the attorney had changed his
mind in the course of just a few days
from equivocation about the legality of
the war to expressing a clear and
unambiguous view that it was lawful when
that was leaked Labour opinion poll
numbers plummeted and a press conference
was held and at that point Gordon Brown
came out for the first time very clearly
and asked would he have done the same
thing he gave a one-word answer yes but
he's never elaborated on that and one of
the things that is interesting is Gordon
Brown has tended to keep his distance
from George W Bush Blair is perceived as
being very close to the American
president and that apparently doesn't
get us down so well with British poll
numbers first call for you comes from
Atlanta Georgia
go ahead Atlanta I must say that I was
opposed to the war from the beginning
because even I who is somewhat a student
of military history could foresee death
and for bush and Blair to say that there
would be no sectarian violence just
shocked me but doesn't surprise me good
military planners even if they really
believed that would have had a plan B
and you might recall here in the US even
before the war
Bush and Cheney let it be known that
they thought that they did not have to
go to Congress nor did they have to go
to the UN my question is do you really
believe that this has shaken the British
and American standing in the world and
is it repairable
well you and I'll hang up and listen for
my answer okay thank you for that very
interesting question there's a couple of
points you raise firstly you focus on
the very important point that at that
meeting in January 2003 the president
told the British prime minister he
didn't think that there was going to be
in Tunis science strife and surprisingly
from my perspective as a Brit the
British prime minister doesn't appear to
respond and say no that's wrong I'm
getting different advice we know that
both President Bush and Prime Minister
Blair were told that they were very
likely to face exactly what has happened
and they both seemed to have discounted
that President Bush in particular and
that raises a fundamental question I
think about competence and it is the
issue that links Katrina and the
response to Katrina with Iraq it's the
seamless web that goes all the way
through now your listeners second
question concerns Britain and America's
standing in the world and here I think
we raise a serious issue
I think Britain and America face a
fundamental threat in relation to global
challenges of terrorism and I think that
the way in which the war has been
prosecuted in Iran has undermined our
ability to respond to that and let me
give you an example I think right now
Iran poses a serious threat in the sense
that it appears committed to obtaining a
nuclear bomb in violation of its
obligations under the treaty on
non-proliferation of nuclear weapons the
NPT treaty and yet Iran now knows that
the appetite for a full response to
future activities by 18 is zero it's not
going to happen and in the United States
I suspect I know the country less well
it's pretty similar and what the tragedy
of Iraq has done is created a space for
others to fill and that I think is the
real concern about what is happening and
so in relation to Britain America's
standing in the world I think there can
be no doubt
that it has fallen very dramatically
America which has been a moral leader
which gave the world a system of global
rules needs I think to find its place
again
and Britain needs I think to speak with
a more independent voice but if you
speak to friends of mine who are
diplomats for Britain and for the United
States uniformly you will be told there
is a real problem now in terms of
credibility and reputation who do you
perceive as filling that space you said
other as well I mean the concern is when
you have a weakened Britain in America
others who will emerge some who may more
be more maligned than others will want
to fill that space I mean I think it's
clear that when the cusp of a changing
world China is becoming increasingly
prosperous increasingly militarily
powerful and the idea of a unipolar
world in which somehow the hyper power
of the United States controls everything
and is able to impose its military will
on others I think has been shown to be
untrue and I think that the United
States will pay a big price our guest is
currently the professor of law and the
director of the center for international
courts and tribunals at university at
college in London he's also a barrister
at matrix chambers a member of the bar
in England and Ireland and your law firm
is that the one the same one were Sharri
bear its Cherie Blair works URI is a
fine and excellent colleague of mine
there are certain subjects obviously we
don't get into into too much detail but
we're a very collegiate barristers
chambers and we co-founded the
organisation together five or six years
ago and she's been a terrific colleague
your book notwithstanding as far as
topics of discussion between you two
we've tended to stare a reasonably wide
berth on the book my name in e Apple s
good morning the whole premise of the
book is quite silly I think it was never
about inspections or a scavenger hunt
it was about disarm and verify post 9/11
we're done playing games
I mean Saddam was not just any dictator
he was dictator with the tremendous
misfortune of losing a war and with that
comes certain obligations I mean he
consistently violated the terms of the
ceasefire and blatantly violated them
and one final point the burden of proof
of WMD was on Saddam Hussein the burden
of proof was never on President Bush
there Tony Blair or
France for the inspectors for the tooth
fairy it was that Saddam Hussein Thanks
well there is the the minor difficulty
of how do you disarm if you don't
actually have any weapons I mean I
recognize that the burden was on Saturn
they're saying to give a full
declaration he gave a declaration in
fact that turned out to be pretty full
and what Britain and the United States
did was set up a mechanism through the
UN to inspect Iraq with a backup of
force if necessary
to determine whether weapons of mass
destruction were there that began to
operate in November and December at 2002
Hans Blix reported on three occasions by
the third occasion on the 7th of March
2003 he was reporting increased Iraqi
cooperation non presence no nuclear
material to speak of and he didn't seem
to find anything in relation to chemical
and bacteriological weapons now I think
if the inspections had carried on we now
know they wouldn't have found anything
and that raises a fundamental question
but it seems clear that the UN mechanism
was a pretext and by January 2003 and
this is where I think the material
that's now come into the public domain
is interesting and potentially
significant by January 2003 it was clear
that the plan of going through the UN
route wasn't going to produce The
Smoking Gun it wasn't going to produce
the evidence so the material indicates
in a sense near panic in some quarters
that the weapons of mass destruction are
not going to be found what do we do next
but I think that in these circumstances
the UN system actually worked pretty
well Sodom Hussein was in fact contained
I'd ask your listener to reflect on this
question after resolution 1441 was
adopted in November 2002 what did Saddam
Hussein do to bring himself into
material breach such as to justify the
use of force in March 2003 it turns out
he gave a pretty accurate declaration he
didn't have weapons of mass destruction
what more could he have done or Felipe's
and amarillo texas hello good morning go
ahead good morning thanks for c-span
it's my first time to call or I've been
trying to cause my first time my
question is what
to mr. Stan's what does corporate what
is the role of corporate America in the
war on Iraq
I mean look George Bush isn't a dummy
and neither is the people around them so
he went to war for a reason you know so
what I think is that it could have been
to secure the the energy for the future
of the needs of the United States and
also Britain with Tony Blair thank you
well that's a if I miss a very important
question again why why did we go to war
there's been a lot of speculation a lot
of ideas was it about oil was it about
promoting interests was it about flexing
muscle at a time of threat from
terrorism from al-qaeda
from abroad I I think that it was
probably a combination of all of the
above was it a desire to if you like
make up for the mistakes that have been
made with the first Bush administration
I think we can speculate till the cows
come home about why America Britain
Australia in a very small number of
countries decided to do it it may
genuinely have been because there was a
belief that there were weapons of mass
destruction notwithstanding the fact
that there was actually no evidence of
weapons of mass destruction and my own
instinct is that it's probably a
combination of all of the above although
it becomes pretty clear as material
emerges here in the United States that
there were some in the administration
mr. Rumsfeld and mr. Cheney and mr.
Wolfowitz in particular who were very
keen even before 9/11 to do something
about weapons of mass destruction and
memos have now emerged from 9/11 itself
the same day hours afterwards saying
let's go for Iraq and I think to
understand why the u.s. went to it you
need to look back to the agenda that
these gentlemen came up with in the late
1990s the project for a new American
Century - essentially flex American
military and economic muscles and might
as a signal to the rest of the world now
that has turned out to be a very
dangerous strategy because it's fine if
it works it's fine if it works you know
the small countries like Grenada or
wherever
but it hasn't worked in relation to Iraq
and the message that has emerged the
United States cannot tame Iraq it's
finding it difficult to tame Afghanistan
isn't going to be able to tame Iran at
the current rate and that sums out a
signal of weakness which I don't think
is a helpful signal and it's why I think
that the project was essentially
misconceived because it was not
carefully thought through in terms of
what would happen if it went wrong did
Tony Blair have his supporters in his
cabinet as well
equivalent to mr. Rumsfeld and others or
their ones that were standing by his
side as far as Iraq was concerned I
think it was more difficult for the
British prime minister to find the level
of support in that sense I think British
Prime Minister was more of an outrider
he was the sort of Rumsfeld and Cheney
of the operation in the domestic British
context a couple of cabinet ministers
resigned other ministers or a small
number also resigned other ministers
stayed on and provided support when you
talk to some of these ministers
privately you know the support was
really rather grudging and we have not
had in Britain the type of views that
have been put by you know mr. Rumsfeld
in mr. Cheney mr. Wolfowitz in terms of
the need for this muscular approach to
Foreign Relations and I think now the
tide may be beginning to turn in the
United States as the forces for a more
newest more cooperative more
multilateral approach come to the fore
and it may well be that secretary
Condoleezza Rice will lead that move
over the coming period reqtest evil
Virginia I think that your guest is
participating in revisionist history and
forgetting the 18 UN resolutions against
Saddam Hussein I think a lot of George
Bush's critics completely forget Bill
Clinton's speech December 16 1998 I
printed that speech off last year when
all of this kind of is coming to my
attention I got it off of cnn.com all
politics you can go and access
that I have it in front of me and it was
the common knowledge of the day when
Bill Clinton struck Iraq when he ordered
airstrikes December 1998 that there were
weapons of mass destruction Bill Clinton
said I quote he says that I have decided
with the unanimous recommendation of my
national security team to use force in
Iraq and he goes on to he goes on and on
I have like eight pages here of this
speech quote the international community
had little doubt then and I have no
doubt today that left unchecked Saddam
Hussein we used these terrible weapons
again and your question to our guest
ma'am what what is his view then I mean
if he thinks George Bush was so wrong to
go in what does he think of all the
things that Bill Clinton said December
16th 1998 mr. samsa I'm not disagreeing
at all with the notion that sat on the
same may have been in material breach on
numerous occasions with various Security
Council resolutions nor with the sense
that he was particularly unpleasant
individual who really oughtn't to be
running any country notwithstanding Iraq
but there's a difference between
recognizing that and what to do about it
and the real issue I think here now
putting aside the legal issues legality
and so on and so forth is whether
focusing on Iraq in March 2003 was a
wise thing to do in two respects firstly
was a proper cost-benefit analysis
carried out in terms of what happened if
it went wrong it's become now pretty
clear that there was no such analysis
and that no real consideration was given
to the possibility that the situation we
are now regrettably in would arise so
that was the first aspect that I think
was significant but but but secondly
what alternatives were there in relation
to prosecuting the response to
terrorist threats Iraq has been a huge
distraction from what is a very real
threat in various parts of the world and
has caused I think human resources
financial resources and political
capital to be lost in relation to a
response where there is a real threat
and that's why I think the issue is not
is that I'm saying a bad man or how bad
is he or should we have got rid of him
was he in material breach or so on and
so forth the real question is was it
wise and was it competent in March 2003
to take the decision that was taken in
the manner it was taken and with the
resources that were applied to it and I
think the answer you know I may well be
wrong and in a sense I hope that I'm
wrong and that in 5-10 years time people
like me approved to have got the facts
wrong
I fear regrettably that isn't going to
be the case and that we as Britain and
as America are severely weakened by what
has happened when it comes to the memos
how did the British press react well
it's it's it's major news in Britain but
it's major news in this sense it simply
confirms what everyone assumed was the
situation and the political body the
public the media obviously are hungry
for hard material for black and white
words which indicate that their worst
fears were met but it's been a very big
issue in Britain Iraq was the decisive
issue in the 2005 May 2005 general
election and it continues to be seeping
away undermining the authority over the
Prime Minister what do you think about
the mere American press reacted well
that's a very interesting question I the
book originally came out in the United
States in October November last year and
I came on a very interesting tour I went
around the country I visited ten cities
I spoke to many people and the reaction
was completely different
I found that I couldn't have even this
type of conversation six months ago
something has changed in the United
States and I was struck by the decision
of the New York Times to go with this as
a front page story it came as a bit of a
surprise to me or that it was placed
above the fold in the New York Times
that seems to have been in a sense
partly a political decision because
in one sense there's nothing new to the
story it already come out in Britain a
couple of months ago and that I think
indicates that there is a change taking
place in the United States and of course
once the New York Times runs with
something like that others pick it up
and it's possible then to engage in
these types of conversations and have
rather hard-hitting discussions about
the merits and demerits of decisions
that were taken in 2003 our guest book
is called lawless world Philippe Sands
is our guest for the next few minutes as
you look at the cover Fort Myers Florida
go ahead please good morning mr. dent I
had a question for you if if you were
wrong a rim and you were surrounded by a
bunch of greedy capitalists globalists
wouldn't you spend a trillion dollars or
just about everything you had to get the
bomb and secondly it has the Iraq of the
Iranian oil bourse
hasn't been released yet have they
started circulating it because this is
an effective kind of removed US dollar
supremacy in the region and I didn't
quite get another euro and this is what
it's all about this is about the oil
business yes about the caller thank you
he asked about the oil and the oil I
guess it hasn't been released and is it
starting to come out of the country and
be sold on the question of oil the I
understand and I'm not an expert in this
area the volume of oil that's being
produced in Iraq is still lower than
before March 2003 the amount being sold
on international markets is still lower
the amount of eight electricity being
generated on a daily basis drinking
water all of this all of these
fundamentals are lower than they were
still now three years ago um in relation
to Iran situation that if I may say is a
very perceptive question and and we find
it in London perhaps and in Washington
difficult to put ourselves in Tehran and
imagine what the view from Tehran is
like and Tehran now finds itself in a
situation in which it is literally
surrounded by neighbors who are either
occupied by the United States or in
close alliance with the United States
and one can see entirely from an Iraqi
perspective and this is not just the
mullahs but I think any Iraq
and that there is a certain nervousness
about what is happening now does that
justify what Iran is doing in relation
to nuclear weapons absolutely not
Iran has signed the treaty on
non-proliferation of nuclear weapons and
it has committed to not developing an
atomic bomb and it appears the material
that has come out before the
International Atomic Energy Agency
indicates that is precisely what Iran is
doing and if people like me are going to
be clear about international rules we
need to be consistent and it can't be
one rule for the United States and one
rule for Iran and so I strongly support
the efforts of the Bush administration
and the European governments to ensure
that Iran complies with its
international obligations the difficulty
of course is that Britain in America
having committed themselves to a path of
lawlessness in relation to Iraq but also
in relation to the treatment of
detainees also in relation to the
interrogation of detainees have in a
sense lost the moral authority to be
able to lecture others on their own
lawlessness and that's why I think the
single most important thing now is to
reconnect to the wonderful American
tradition supported by the United
Kingdom of working within a rule of law
system and that needs to happen sooner
rather than later so if President Bush
comes to the prime minister for support
on Iran what happens well the issue of
military action is some ways off but you
will have read in this morning's paper
that the Security Council has adopted a
measure yesterday in relation to Iran
read the story very carefully
they haven't adopted a resolution
they've adopted something called a
declaration and my understanding is that
one of the reasons that has happened is
that the fear with what happened with
Iraq of adopting a resolution then
claiming that Iraq was in material
abridge has led China to certain extent
France to a certain extent Russia to
hold back from saying well let's not go
the resolution route yet let's leave it
at a lower level and it's it's
undermining our ability to respond to
real issues Moline Illinois good morning
good morning your guests the US standing
in the world has fallen oh I see so war
it's a good thing you stand standing as
is falling now we Bush can focus more on
means poverty in the southern United
States and the free clinic Katrina a New
Orleans I don't think it was a mistake
to go to war with the British because
most British people like the New York
Times internationalist pudding they
probably think the United States is an
empire like like the Roman Empire so I
think we should mind our own business we
should be more isolationist and we
should fight poverty at home instead of
going around the world and turn other
people want to do so the way to fight
the war on terror is to secure the
American border deal you know we make
your poses more introspective deal with
American people and leave the world
alone thank you you know that's all well
and good but we live in a complex
globalized world and America needs to
the rest of the world and the rest of
the world needs America why do we need
America America is a unique country
America is the country that gave the
world in large part the modern system of
international law and international
rules President Roosevelt President
Truman and President Eisenhower played
an absolutely extraordinary role in
putting in place the basic rules of
international law that now litter the
landscape that Geneva Conventions the
human rights conventions the free trade
agreements the foreign investment
protection agreements and American legal
creativity American ideas American
idealism have pushed all of these things
and we need America pushing in their
direction and promoting those rules and
that's why I think events over the last
three to four years the abdication of
that leadership role the abdication of
that role of responsibilities is very
problematic and I don't think
isolationism is the way out America's
economic situation is largely dependent
on its relations with the rest of the
world and so America's standing with the
rest of the world matters both in terms
of domestic well-being and in terms of
America's ability to influence
internationally our guest has his
education from Cambridge was born and
raised in London in England and lives
there Garret Park New York Garret Park
Maryland good morning yes thank you
thank you c-span
thank you especially for question time I
really enjoy listening the British
Parliament I daresay our government
couldn't withstand such exposure in the
media I wanted to thank your guest for
his book
I completely agree with his position I
have to say as formerly twenty years of
the Republican I had to delist from the
party three years ago after deciding I
no longer shared those values and that
those values were not even conservative
my question is does the author perceive
in the the sea change that he is
indicating of in popular opinion that
the there is a cognitive dissonance that
is slightly being overcome by that I
mean those who have been conned and
those who have been sold a bill of goods
and lied to and have accepted the lie on
extremely difficult to accept the fact
that they were fooled and when that
becomes apparent given the fact that
they are more and more emerging will
consistently Kent will continue to deny
the truth and deny those facts in order
to protect that safe feeling that they
have that they were competent listeners
competent thinkers who could not have
been fooled particularly at the cost of
2500 American lives and countless others
in Iraq well just just to help you all
your viewers and listeners a little I am
British and I'm based in London but I'm
pretty closely connected to the u.s. my
wife is American my kids were born here
in the United States and so I followed
very very closely and I happened to be
in New York on 9/11 I was teaching at
NYU Law School I was a mile from the
Twin Towers I saw the whole thing
happening it was a deeply deeply
shocking and affecting experience so I'm
acutely aware of the shock that came to
that city and of the shock that came to
the country although it's something of
course growing up in London we were to a
certain extent sensitized to because of
the IRA bombings in the 1970s in
particular and in the 1980s but I don't
think however dreadful what happened on
9/11 was that it justified the slack
that was given to the Bush
administration to respond as it did and
in a sense the country went to sleep in
a way that I found
gave rise to serious concerns political
opposition melted away the media didn't
test issues didn't test the arguments
mass public opinion took a long time to
wake up and there's a serious question I
think to be asked the United says why
did that happen how could that be
allowed to have happened now I'm not
sure that I said that a sea change is
happening but plainly things are
beginning to change the president is now
being critiqued political opposition
even to a certain extent if the
Democratic Party is beginning to test
some of these issues and I think coming
to your viewers question that is because
there is a recognition that the policies
that were put in place after 9/11 the
dismembering of the legal rules the
treatment of detainees the situation at
Guantanamo the war in Iraq have not
provided America with greater security
have not provided America with greater
well-being and coupled with the issues
that I raised at the beginning which are
fundamentally issues of competence
I think Katrina opened the door because
all of a sudden people began to see that
actually the issue of competence on
which President Bush prides himself was
perhaps not as powerful as he thought
and I think the lack of confidence in
the competence issue has opened the door
I'm not sure whether or not they'll be a
sea-change and I I fear that if there
was to be another attack in the United
States similar to the scale of 9/11 the
door may close again very quickly but I
hope not
Riverside California yes I've been
listening carefully and I have a
question on 9/11 we were attacked you
were there you said we were attacked by
whom by radical Islamics what would you
have what would you have done nothing
well absolutely not I we've done nothing
I mean I've already said on the program
I supported very strongly the immediate
response in relation to Afghanistan it
became pretty clear that the source of a
lot of the trouble was coming from the
fact that the Taliban government in
Afghan
stan was taking no steps to control
various groups al-qaeda in particular
mr. bin Laden in particular from
mounting these and possibly also other
attacks and I think in those
circumstances the United States was
fully justified to take the measures
that it did in responding with military
force to protect itself in exercise of
self-defense I have no problem with any
of that at all I have a problem with the
way some of the war in Afghanistan is
now being conducted but that's a
different issue so certainly I would
have done something what I would not
have done what I think was fundamentally
misconceived terrible mistake was to
declare a war on terror this is not a
war by characterizing it as a war the
individuals our viewers just referred to
Islamic fundamentalists I think he
called them had been raised from the
status of criminals to the status of
warriors and that has completely changed
the dynamic in which the way the rest of
world opinion has followed once apon
it's been be much more difficult to get
allies and I think the setting aside of
rules of criminal law which ought have
been modified obviously to take into
account a more serious threat was a
fundamental mistake and has got the
United States into the position that it
was a decision that was taken for
political reasons the president needed
to position himself as a wartime
president but this is not a war that we
are currently engaged in to give you an
example Britain in 1960s the 1970s was
faced with a call by the IRA to
recognize that they were combatants that
they were involved in an armed struggle
and the British government said no we're
not going to do that we're not going to
elevate your status in order to pander
to your political desires and give you
that that type of enhanced status and
the right decision was taken to
prosecuted essentially under refined
criminal laws and that should have
happened here we talked we started
talking about legacy in history for Tony
Blair what does he do between now when
he leaves - to preserve a as far as what
history will say to him about him in
Iraq
I think it's reached the point where
it's no longer in his hands it's out of
his control
it's circumstances in Iraq and elsewhere
will determine his political legacy and
his